what's up this is Akash Singh and you're
about to see me on the bootleg Kev
podcast don't watch nothing else YouTube
retention numbers got to go up give it
the full time
bootleg Camp podcast special guests
we're live in New York City
Akash what's up welcome sir thank you
for having me man of course man of
course I've been a big fan of you for a
long time thank you so much
um it's always crazy when someone I'm a
fan of tells me they've watched my stuff
I'm like that's great get out of here
dude yeah dude your special uh which
came out what it was like four or five
months ago now yeah it came out February
of 2012. crazy special thank you so much
man
um I remember like first kind of diving
into like flagrant when it was uh the
original crew yeah um cash that's the
cast and it was like kind of like a
weird Sports podcast but it evolved into
something else like super yeah very fast
yeah
um but for people who don't know like
what were the original like because
obviously Andrew went from like Guy Code
to brilliant idiots and then launching
flagrant
um what was kind of like the original
crew like what was the original
I guess theme of The Show for because
now it's it's its own it's its own thing
it's way different than it was yeah yeah
yeah going super far back when Andrew
started brilliant idiots I said to him
out loud this is the only time I've ever
been jealous of you right as when you're
when he was doing the podcast with
Charlemagne right and it wasn't like
real jealousy but like really what I was
thinking in my brain was I had nothing I
wasn't on guy because I wasn't on TV so
he had to take that opportunity
Charlemagne's amazing and huge so I was
like you got to do that but in my mind I
was like if we did a podcast I think
that [ __ ] would go oh right so I but I
obviously go crush it brilliant it just
did great and then when Andrew started
talking about do us doing a podcast a
few years later I think he felt like he
wanted to start another thing also I was
obviously down and we had been kind of
like brainstorming and uh we did a
brilliant episode with Kaz we thought
Cavs was great so we brought him on
board and then the idea of doing sports
which I love sports I could talk sports
yeah you guys yeah you always are
throwing your little tidbits in about
sports that make me feel like oh he's a
real Sports yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and
Andrew likes sports but but he also
understood something that we had talked
about which is like yo we can slowly dip
into these crazy things we say like when
we're hanging out just saying wild jokes
about whatever right but an easy entry
point is sports because sports fans tend
to not get super triggered about
anything right right they're not it's
not too political It's Just Sports so
the idea was always to evolve it into
something else and then Alex got more
and more involved and that was amazing
he was so funny and like we would
encourage him when he would chime in
we'd be like dude you're funny chime in
yeah and then Mark Andrew started
working with Mark and Mark is a
brilliant kid super funny super talented
he's a star and I didn't know him that
well and he's doing stand-up now he does
yeah he's well he started as a stand-up
I didn't know that NBA he's been doing
Santa for years and that's how him and
Andrew connected got you he opened for
Andrew and then uh Andrew brought him on
board he was like he's a smart kid he
has like good ideas for Merch and all
this stuff a lot of the set design of
the new set was more the set's crazy um
yeah he does so much of our YouTube
stuff he's a [ __ ] brilliant kid and
so when Andrew was like I want to start
bringing mark on the pot I was like yeah
I don't know I'm super well but bring
him on and then I got to know him he's a
great kid and it just evolved into
flagrant and then when we built the new
studio we wanted to try to find a place
for them as well right on camera because
they contribute so much off camera yeah
for sure it's just evolved into this
like four guy hang it is definitely a
hang yeah and I love it because it is
like the most I'm saying the crazy [ __ ]
I always you know when the podcast is on
or my wife's in the car she's always
like what the [ __ ] are you listening to
yeah what's wrong with you my wife
doesn't listen there's episodes where
I'm like hey I think you'll like this
one yeah listen to this one don't listen
to this one because you might divorce me
yeah yeah she's just like all right fine
no it's great because it's like today's
uh you know obviously climate it's just
nice to have a place where like there's
just zero [ __ ] yeah well I think Andrew
probably knew this on some level and I
maybe did but I won't even give myself
that much credit if you think about like
when somebody when there's always this
like uh there's always
too much like is an over correctness for
anything of course there's always a
little voice that's dissenting and like
we don't need all this so when
everybody's getting so PC and so PC I
think we were the first one of the first
at least to be like yo [ __ ] all that
let's just have fun and if the intention
is to be funny and not to hurt feelings
great Andrew I said Judge Me by my
intentions and I've always agreed with
that like that's a comedy right yeah
that's comedy we're trying to be funny
if I'm trying to hurt your feelings in a
hateful way then [ __ ] me but if we're
just trying to be funny and I'm making
it all funny then great has ever been a
a a a episode or like a moment where you
were a little nervous about
whether they cancel culture people were
covered for y'all or not cancel culture
or just or just like you know because I
feel like obviously if you come from a
traditional Indian background you know
what I mean but there you guys be saying
some [ __ ] on there man you know what I
just in my mind I'm like my parents
don't know how to use the internet I
don't know why but I like it it's so
stupid but I'm like my mom is 67 she's
not using this she's not she's not
diving into the corner a seven minute
Mark of this episode yeah it don't
matter yeah so I don't ever consider it
and I've told them from the moment I
started stand up I was like don't watch
don't watch I just say just if I'm
making money be happy for me but please
don't watch because I can't live with it
because I do think about that a lot even
like the roasts like the the roast that
Andrew will do so like he just did the
Kanye one yeah yeah but uh man some of
those roast lines are [ __ ] oh good
they're crazy yeah the Will Smith one oh
it was so good oh yeah and I felt like
we I think we both felt personally like
yo [ __ ] this guy yeah yeah yeah yeah and
then we every he just those roast lines
were crazy I didn't I'm not gonna take
credit for writing those jokes that was
him and well what like [ __ ] dude those
are great jokes yeah the Will Smith
thing was something where it was like it
was kind of dope to see like uh just all
the comedians just kind of gang up on
what on somebody yeah and it was like it
was done in a way that was like
so late like the jokes that came from
right were like maybe it was worth Chris
Rock taking this left for all the comedy
we got out of it
for a night and uh and and we got some
great comedic moments from it yo I
really think Will Smith is like he
opened the floodgates for all of the
attacks oh for sure so what's his name
Solomon Rusty getting salmon Rusty
getting uh stabbed on stage yeah that
shit's crazy I think it's this just the
girl getting the beer thrown at her it's
all open now you think that kind of like
had a little bit to do with like having
people get a little you know obviously
uh emboldened to do some [ __ ] like that
yeah this is a crazy crazy comparison
you know how Columbine there weren't
really school shootings and then after
Columbine people were like yo that's a
possibility that's the thing like
deranged people were like oh that's what
I did that was like the first one yeah
well in a much less significant and well
I'm not saying the significance of
saying but like on a smaller much
smaller level people are at comedy shows
and their brain is just open to the
possibility deranged people are like I
could [ __ ] this guy up yeah and I'm a
[ __ ] guy like I'm a very [ __ ]
person yeah so I've always kind of had
an awareness of that and like I never
wanted to cross a line I also don't want
to be so disrespectful that you should
beat me up but you won't because I'm
small like I try to play with the line
and I'll say it shows like hey if you're
genuinely if you feel like I cross the
line if you just don't want me to talk
to you just give me something like this
and then we'll move on oh like like if
you do the crowd work thing yeah yeah
but now I'm like I do it earlier I'm
like I need to make sure y'all are aware
of this and then if you give me this
We're not gonna try to do this yeah
columbine's kind of like the Sugar Hill
Gang of school shooting
for sure
right it's like
just I said a hip hop first hit the
first hit the first hip hop hit right
okay it was like the message foreign
yo it really is it's like weird too
because now like my uh I think it was
one of my nieces was showing me like on
Tick Tock there's like a whole like
underbelly of girls who are like um that
worship like the the shooters like what
I remember the names of the kids from
Columbine but like there's like a full
like fan girl club of like 19 year old
girls who like you know [ __ ] play
with themselves while looking at
pictures of these dudes or whatever it's
pretty wild but you know what Andrew has
a joke about this every school shooter
says the same thing uh nobody wanted to
have sex with me all these in cells are
the ones that so these girls could be a
very valuable asset you just gotta
started [ __ ] the guys you just gotta
start [ __ ] the guys listen to ICP and
you know [ __ ] go off don't shower
suck a couple dicks somebody should do
the like the 4chan grinder you know yeah
yeah 100 yes 69 Chan
16. let's do it oh man so for you like
um talk about just like obviously your
come up as a comedian
um you were telling me earlier that you
started doing comedy on uh Cali I
started in LA in like 07. okay so that's
damn oh seven yeah so I'm about 15 years
deep now yeah I did a couple times in
college but then I really started when I
was in 07 I moved to LA on a whim for
that or just yeah before that and I
didn't know you were supposed to move to
New York my but my best friend was going
there to be a cinematographer okay my
other best friend from college we
convinced him to go because he was going
to go there in a year to be an actor
yeah and a musician so I was like yo
let's just all go and then I got my
mom's blessing which was a man
everything I wouldn't have gone without
that but yeah I started in 07 and like
man it was rough but then everybody told
me a year and a half I was actually
doing fairly well in La like open mics
and I think they looked at me not like
this kid is a star but they looked at me
like this is the kid that's going to be
really funny one day right right right
but the vets would tell me specifically
the black vets would tell me you're in
the wrong place to get funny you go to
New York to get funny and then you come
to LA to get famous and I knew I wanted
to be funny more than I wanted to be
famous as great as famous would be I was
like I need funny I can't live if I'm
not good at comedy I can't live with
myself I'm famous and shitty at comedy
so I moved to New York and then that was
that was rough but it was very worth it
but it was rough so originally before
you moved to Cali where are you
originally from Dallas oh you're from
Dallas originally Southwest I used to uh
well I I had a girl I was [ __ ] with
that was a um Twin Peaks waitressing
planet in Plano Texas Peaks oh my God I
didn't know you [ __ ] white girls
bootlegates no definitely not why
not
lovely
uh younger sister in uh Plano Texas
about six years ago Twin Peaks
I don't know man
it's the only time
what's in time for Wrestlemania in like
2015. okay we had a hotel in Plano I
went to a strip club
that was called Onyx maybe I don't know
but yeah it was like a BYOB strip club
which they don't have I think that's
just in Texas I've been a one may have
been a couple to bring your own bottles
I had been in one strip club by the time
I was like 27 or something and then I
got a free lap dance because I was so
uncomfortable that the girl thought it
was hilarious yeah to just give me a lap
dance yeah the whole uh the strip club
Dynamic is interesting son it's a
terrible place it's there's no cemetery
on Earth As Dead As a stripper's eyes
and they just sit on your lap and just
just like assume that that's what you
want and then when you say ah now I'm
good they get up and they it's like
they're offended it goes from nice to
attitude so fast yeah yeah yeah it's
like I'm here for chicken wings yeah oh
you know I'm here because my friend
wants to get the leg talk to him I'm
just hanging out 100 there's a bachelor
party 95 of the time so what are we
doing yeah the saddest thing I remember
watching the guys like put the dollar
bills like on the ground or whatever it
wasn't even as sad as at the end of the
song watching them Scurry the strippers
to pick up like eight dollars I was like
yo this is sad though that is the most
uh demeaning part of the strip club
experience is at the end of the girls
stage she has to bend down and she has
to I would rather if I'm a woman I think
I'd rather you put it in my [ __ ]
g-string ass crack yeah then I got a
Scurry like a mouse especially if they
make it rain like there's a there's a
club in L.A called Sam's that's like uh
the middle stage is just full of like 10
girls yeah and if I make it rain on one
girl every girl on stage has a right to
any of the money that touches the stage
so when people make it rain it's like
throwing [ __ ] pigeon food at the park
it's [ __ ] crazy it's like it's like
it's like the funnest strip club to go
to if you really want to just be a piece
of [ __ ] and watch chicks hit the floor
and like die for money you're like let
me get 100 once and cause some [ __ ]
chaos completely generate that would be
fun yeah you know it's not bad so being
from Dallas you're like a Cowboys guy
yeah yeah I wish I wasn't but I have to
Mavericks yeah of course I mean Luca you
know because that's fun to root for the
Cowboys 28 years of just for health
or whatever yeah yeah dude it's so funny
to watch because I still listen to a
sports radio station in Dallas till this
day I mean I'm from Phoenix so that's
what I do I listen to my local station
on tune in and then yeah that's that all
I care about is Arizona Sports I don't
give a [ __ ] about the Lakers or I'm sure
you don't care about the Yankees or
anything no I truly don't the Knicks
being bad is funny to me right like I
would I would like to be here when
they're good because you right because
you're a basketball fan yeah when Sandy
happened you could feel it right right
right right by energy I don't normally
feel it but when the sanity was
happening you could feel the whole city
buzzing yeah so if the Knicks were good
good which they might be uh that'd be
fun but generally speaking I think it's
funny to watch the next fans suffer so
you were here during the insanity moment
yeah yeah yeah and that was as close to
an Indian basketball players we'd ever
had so I would type right yeah that's my
guy you guys have never had a NBA player
ever no well we had said Nam Singh who's
in the D-League right the gas Punjabi
dude like seven three one speaks English
but you guys do have the uh what's the
name of the wrestler uh the great the
great Khalid he's he's we also have oh
my God I can't believe this guy's I
don't remember this guy's name he
follows me on Twitter I've hung out with
him what is his name Jinder Mahal Jinder
Mahal yeah yeah I'm a big wrestling guy
god dude yo my badge in there shout out
to gender I hung out with him in Tampa
before nice guys dude sweetest guy
definitely on steroids he he tells me
he's not but I'm like he is it's okay
yeah he went from being like kind of a
chubby bigger dude he got fired and then
he bounced back and he was [ __ ]
shredded like a Mania I'm like yo this
guy's six months the craziest turn
around the steroids are serious his
shoulders are nuts yeah I'm wondering
man because you're one of the you know
obviously you were lucky enough to be
able to go on uh Joe's Joe Rogan's
podcast yeah you always hear that like
he's the king maker yeah right did you
notice I mean obviously you guys have a
crazy phone you guys got one of the
biggest patreons you guys have your own
Universe you're in you're already
selling out dates your special was doing
well but did you notice the like uptick
in everything yes after going on the
show my so My Views it was cool it was
like trending on YouTube the first
couple days and it was like then it hit
like 300 000 and like whatever two days
and then you could see it level off for
weekends I've used on YouTube and then
the second the Rogan dropped it doubled
it hit another 300 000 in the next two
days and that's completely it would have
done this right but with Rogan it did
this
and it was like it might even be any
more I've been like two and a half X or
whatever yeah you see and he's the
[ __ ] greatest the the experience is
intense because like we're chilling
we're hanging out we're leaning back you
know how how many people are listening
to Rogan and he's gonna give you every
ounce of attention possible so if I
don't return that I'm a giant [ __ ]
you know he's locked in he's locked the
[ __ ] in yeah and for that guy worth that
much with that much power to be locked
in for two hours with you or however
long if I don't return it who the [ __ ]
am I that's right so I was like you know
what I mean like yeah I went there
during uh like covet I went there with
Freddie Gibbs and um
you know I I had it in my head uh what I
thought it might be yeah but it's like
kind of like in like a little like
business complex where there's like a
doctor's office and [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
and I was like I was a little I was like
damn I really expected to come to like
some giant Warehouse with like weights
everywhere I think there's a lot of [ __ ]
in the back there probably is yeah
because Andrew is telling me I had to
get [ __ ] swapped just to walk in
there yeah yeah yeah they were playing
they're not playing if Andrew's telling
me he did like a like he Joe shot like a
bow and arrow from like 100 yards out
and just like crazy hit some crazy
Bullseye or something but it was in that
facility so I think it's a whole thing
um you guys I feel like obviously Andrew
I think I I credited him to changing how
people consume comedy really did how
they think of comedy and I think um
kind of the Innovation you know I think
when we go through something like covid
right yeah it kind of forces you to
change your approach to whatever your
own livelihood is yes yeah and I I just
think back to the like turn your phone
this way brilliant and how it just kind
of changed just you know the way people
and I know Louis CK was releasing
specials on his own but just like on the
YouTube side like I can't really think
of anybody doing the YouTube so I know
in India they were doing a lot of Comedy
clips online because that was the only
way they could do stand up right get it
out there but Andrew was the first guy
in America which is kind of where
everybody's looking for right The
Guiding Light of stand up to be like yo
nobody's buying the special I'm just
going to put it out online and if it
wasn't for that I wouldn't not only
because he's done so much for me but
like I wouldn't be able to sell any
tickets on my own because now I'm
selling tickets through just stand-up
Clips because I saw that model so I'm
like oh and now you're scrolling through
IG it's nauseating how much stand up
there is it is very nauseating for sure
because I follow a lot of comedians like
[ __ ] everybody's got a [ __ ] even some
of these guys are just not funny it's
they absolutely should do it you gotta
do it right sometimes I'll see the crowd
work stuff and I'll be like
yeah the crowd yeah it's rough it's
rough luckily we were forged in the
comedy club where we came up wasn't even
a comedy club it was called the Village
Lantern is a bar upstairs and then
downstairs in the basement there was
nobody there and they would just let us
do stand up we would get people off the
street bring them down if you had five
people you could do a show oh that's
dope so but five people I can't do my
bits for five people right you gotta
interact you gotta interact with those
people yeah I was like there's even
three people sometimes they'd be looking
at me like are you [ __ ] oh you is
this are you a human being dude right
right so you had to learn to talk to
them you had to learn to interact you
had to get your crowd Work Sharp so we
had years of that before we started
dropping Clips with crowd work hey we
got to stop the interview real quick to
tell you about our newest partner to the
podcast shout out to our family at
hardean Las Vegas man listen uh the
number one dispensary in the world I
don't give a [ __ ] man craziest
dispensary with the most selection they
got so much weed in this [ __ ] place
you go to Las Vegas you're [ __ ]
feeling good with your homies it's
recreational you're like damn I could
just go into a store and buy weed yeah
but you just can't go going to any store
in Las Vegas to buy weeds you know walk
out with some [ __ ] [ __ ] no you go
to hard Dean tell them I sent you all
right make sure you follow them online
Harding underscore Las Vegas you see it
down there you see the [ __ ]
sweater we represent and by the way can
we shout out
to them for sending me this this bootleg
head podcast
thingy
what is this called no no it's uh for
cigars
humidor yeah the humidor now this is
what's great about it we might start
doing this for our smoking guests
you know we might have to bust open the
Hardy and humidor and just get into some
of these treats you know what I'm saying
a little bit of the treaties you know
straight from Hardy in Las Vegas even I
mean
these are totally props because you know
they're props but with that being said
when you go to Vegas telling bootleg Kev
sent you Jardin Las Vegas I'm telling
you it is like going to it's like the
Bentley of dispensaries it's so nice the
weed is the best the selection is the
best the bud tenders are the best and yo
make sure you shoot them a follow
Harding underscore Las Vegas go to
hardinglasvegas.com and when you're in
Vegas
go to hardine baby all right you already
know let's get back to the interview yo
where would you say like uh for you
obviously the the podcast helps water
everything because it's so massive
um do you feel like being you guys are
on camera a lot every week sometimes two
episodes a week always one two and a
patreon sometimes a one on a patreon but
at least two sometimes three it's a lot
of time right yeah so yeah do you ever
feel like uh is it does it does it take
away from the comedy because it's so
it's it's so much bandwidth towards that
or do you feel like they kind of like
one hand washes the other you you have
one hand watch the other but the
struggle being married and trying to be
a good husband of course is I'll lamp
Sunday from his weekend of doing shows
we'll have a call about Monday's episode
month so I prep for that when I get home
spend like an hour of my wife prep for
the episode Monday the episode Tuesday
and spend a little time with my wife
hopefully Monday night Tuesday we got
two episodes on the next day sometimes
so I'll do that or I'm doing like voice
over for a Hulu show or a Netflix show
so I'll do both of those or you know
just then Wednesday two episodes then
Thursday I'm out of town for shows
Thursday Friday Saturday damn how long
is your marriage going to last without
us that's the thing I don't want to be
the guy I want to be the greatest comic
ever but I don't want to be the greatest
comic ever alone that's the saddest [ __ ]
in the world to me is these guys who are
all the way up not the saddest but I
don't think it's worth it yeah you see
guys like I mean not even the same names
but you see guys who get divorced and
they're like yeah you're that
[ __ ] but you're also kind of you
know you're hanging out with me until
three in the morning you're 54 years old
go home man yeah you're going home alone
and you don't want to do that and that's
not I'm not picking on people but I
always said I can't ha I have to have
both and I can't give up my wife right I
mean I think with anything they're
sacrificed so as long as she's like
knows what's up she kind of knows she
knows herself but you're also gonna you
got kids if I want kids I don't want
kids to necessarily know us up yeah
that's my dad he got to go do his thing
but yeah he's not any of my baseball
games no that's real man I mean you miss
[ __ ] bro like I mean I I mean as busy
even as busy as I am like and I try to
make sure that I'm there as much as I
can be but just sometimes you just gotta
you're gonna miss some [ __ ] but I need
to make he needs to feel like my dad is
there when I need him my dad is there
for a lot of [ __ ] if not ever yeah and
eventually you're going to get to the
point where you're printing money and
you know you could just take a private
jet to make the soccer game that's what
I'm hoping I am hoping like at a certain
point is there's a lot more time for
family and a little less uh a little
less busy how um for you uh obviously
coming from your culture I always would
hear that there'd be like arranged
marriages right yes that's a real thing
100 my parents now it's a very fluid
thing now now you your parents might be
like hey our family knows this person
you guys will date for a while and then
be like so it's more like a setup right
but there are a range of marriages my
dad didn't know he was getting married
till his wedding day she was so he
didn't know who he was marrying not only
did he not know who he was marrying he
didn't know he was getting married
period until his wedding day how old was
he when he married your mom 24. what the
[ __ ] so how does so so give me that
their story even uncles and aunties that
hear it are like that's bananas like
imagine you don't know you're getting
married and then he was at another
wedding yeah and his cousins came up and
they were like you tell him you tell him
he's like somebody tell me and they said
you're getting married today so he's in
the car going over there getting fitted
for a suit taking measurements because
my mom was in America at the time she
went to America when she was she didn't
know her real age but they listed at 14
and then she was there for like a finite
amount of time and my dad's family not
even a media family but like they
thought immediate family is actually his
uncle was like high up in the Indian
government so my mom's family was like
this is great he's from a good family
these guys are set up and then my dad's
family was like she's a pretty girl
she's in America this is great same cast
same everything right let's just get it
done what's a cast
in Hinduism now I don't know if this is
implemented by the I should research
more I've heard is implemented by the
Brits I've heard us not but in Hinduism
there are casts okay and it's like a
class of people kind of it is classist
but my understanding was always that it
is supposed to be more like an assembly
line than a class system more like hey
you guys are focused on this thing you
guys are focused on my cast ironically
because I'm so small as the warrior cast
Okay because like look y'all if we go to
war y'all uh [ __ ] there that's what
you're worried about right if you're the
laborer cast you are working that's what
you're working on can you ever upgrade
cash which is that's but again if it's
not done in a classist way right no big
deal right but but it kind of It kind of
has to be I mean it you know yeah but
it's gonna humans are gonna do that now
again I've my wife was telling me she
wrote a book my wife's not into she's a
seek sick okay but uh she was saying she
read another book where they're like no
that's very much baked in the Hinduism I
didn't pick that up I need to read a
little better uh but yeah the idea was
just like hey this is the most efficient
way yeah like if you're in the working
class it's like
you you just know that this is your life
like yeah there should be someone else
I'm gonna be honest if I'm born and you
look at me and I'm 15 years old and I'm
5'2 and 160 pounds or whatever I was
back then you gotta be like this ain't
no Warrior okay do something else okay
this guy marching class he's good with
money yeah you know I mean there should
have been but again this was uh this is
the oldest religion so it's
four thousand years ago five thousand
years ago we're talking so did your mom
know she was getting married she knew it
was a possible so she knew it might
happen she met the family yeah and she
was like okay but it wasn't that much
say in it what the [ __ ] I mean she could
have said no so was it like your dad's
parents decision to be like you're
getting married today like who who makes
the call I think my dad's parents or
maybe my dad's uncle again who's like
the more like um like the patriarch
right uh but yeah I don't know exactly
who decided he doesn't I don't even know
he didn't even care who decided and your
parents love each other
[Laughter]
I will say I have seen it's just like
the the rates are the same as what we
call love marriages okay where it seems
like half the couples I see that
arranged they're like they're really in
love they make it work it's a beautiful
thing and then the other half is like oh
this never should have happened this is
like a business relationship yeah or
just you guys aren't even yeah there's
some rough ones yeah the husband is a
monster whatever though you know but at
the same time you look at American
marriage this is a 52 divorce rate or
whatever yeah it's 50 50. what I feel
like I've learned I don't want to be
arrogant to act like I have the keys to
marriage and Fidelity and all of that
but what I think I've learned is if both
of y'all are willing to do the work
because you will make it that seems like
what yeah and I think I think that's
what most people they give up when
things get [ __ ] you know what I mean
yeah when they get rough when you hit a
rough spot it's like most people just
give up or they cheat or they you know
they pull the plug a little early
irreconcilable differences is the thing
that we always just say but like how
many differences are really irrational
yeah like he he hits you right he
assaults you in any way he is abusive in
any way or maybe maybe he cheats
she cheats that's irreconcilable He
Cheats I feel like yeah I mean we can
reconcile this of course it's a lot more
intimate when a woman cheats like you
got a guy inside of you right yeah it's
definitely a sexist approach but it's
true how dare you dude yeah yeah
definitely I agree with you man yeah
dude yeah for sure ladies come on be
decent you know
um like now that obviously you got the
special out are you trying like what is
like you I always hear comedians on
podcast talking like uh once every two
years some guys do once a year for you
what is like you know ideally the time
that you want to take between specials I
feel like I have uh something right now
I don't know if I want to do the hour
unless there's like a crazy bag or
whatever right even Andrew doing the
hour he was like it's a lot to do an
hour now he made it work and he made
it's great and it's doing well on
YouTube but an hour to me always felt
like who's gonna watch for an hour an
hour's a long time man and I've even
heard that like stand-ups are starting
to put like the closing [ __ ] at the
front end that was a movie thing yeah it
was like to get his hour up he'd put the
closer at the beginning but even yeah
for YouTube retention yeah and I have a
closing bit that I really like and I bet
it is a long it's like I sit down I take
like it's my favorite bit I've ever done
right I feel like this is my next level
right but it's like an eight minute
thing and it's spaced very slowly yeah
my fear is on YouTube they're gonna be
like I ain't watching this [ __ ] there
was a Mr Beast video I can watch right
now yeah where's the minute clip yeah
yeah yeah so I don't necessarily know
how to do it I feel like when I build
this thing up I want to find a creative
way to do it yeah I have something I
feel like I could put out really you
know a little bit of work but then I
also want to find what's the most
creative way to do it I really was proud
of the way I did bring back a poo I was
proud of the message I was trying to
send two more people and I was proud of
that whole thing now there was like a
delivery mechanism I was like this is it
I see it I don't necessarily see it with
this and when I do then it's it doesn't
matter how long it's let's go do you
feel like you're kind of like a helping
kick down the door for like you know
because we would always I mean you've
talked about it but just like Indians
and entertainment would always be at
least in the US obviously the Indian
movie space is wild it's like its own
world but like in terms of like us
casting it's always like super
typecasted [ __ ] but I feel like that's
been coming like a lot less like like
I think in general would just most races
that aren't white or black like yeah
um it's opening up a lot more but I
think on the comedy side like I think
like you kind of a really like faced a
lot of those like stereotypes or a lot
of those like conceptions about your
people in the entertainment industry
head-on do you feel like you're kind of
helping kind of change that narrative a
bit in a way now I always had a
different take on like I got a lot of
those stereotypical or whatever but I
always had a different take on what's
offensive to me and what's not right
most people and I think a lot of times
people kind of and this is what bring
back a pool is also kind of fighting
back against I think is a lot of
minorities will take white people's
guilt about what has been done in the
past which is [ __ ] but they will
really exploit that and Hammer that home
and the point of their comedy is to make
them feel bad and that was a way to like
elevate your own profile and get your
money those guys don't often really help
out Indians or brown people there's one
Entertainer I see who's really doing it
you know Rami Yusuf right yeah that
[ __ ] is about it dude his show
is not about guilting anybody and then
he puts all his homies on he's doing a
show for Mo armor Mo yeah that's Rami
that helped get that done it's a great
show if you are brown and talented
Romney will do what he can to elevate
you and I feel like that's the way to do
it I think what a lot of we see is like
um oh I get Typecast as you know accents
and then they just do that to get ahead
yeah and the other thing too was like yo
why is like a boo is like a he's like
obviously like a he's a business owner
yeah you know what I'm saying he's got a
family yeah he's great things yeah about
that character now was he voiced by a
white guy sure yeah and if you wanted to
if this if it was hey just have an
Indian dude do the voice cool but it
wasn't that it was a lot of oh my God
look at the struggle we go through and
it's not fun to get made fun of with the
Apu accent but like you can't possibly
compare that to what black people have
been through in America when gay people
have been through in America you're
doing this to get ahead I just know for
a fact you are none of you got PTSD from
this [ __ ] and if there may be a couple
of you most you don't got PTSD from this
right like it's not a thing right it's
not stop it and I hope what I see a lot
of minorities do to get ahead is kind of
take the liberal side of everything
right and I'm not conservative I do
think I'm very moderate I think nowadays
man
I traditionally am a liberal guy yeah
but I swear the last three years hasn't
made me like just pulled me to the
Middle where I'm just like I don't know
100 everybody's batshit crazy 100 and we
should be allowed to say that without uh
upsetting and still get opportunities it
should be okay to say that and I do
think I'm it's before it was either you
know you are the liberal guy and I'm not
picking on him but Aziz was doing a lot
of that before yeah a lot of it dude a
lot it was they called him woke Bay yeah
even like his last stand-up I I got like
five minutes in and I was like all right
it was a lot of like you started really
lean in that one yeah rewarded for it or
you'd got to do the Candace Owens thing
which is also it's even worse it's
insane it's gross but you can't just be
like a modern guy who's like yo both
y'all are [ __ ] crazy as a minority
felt like you couldn't do that and I
hope that's what I can do yeah it's okay
to push back on either side I think
that's what as during the pandemic I
think that was also a great thing that
you guys provided was just like
unadulterated like non-partisan
just [ __ ] both sides we have to offend
everybody I feel that [ __ ] both sides
yeah it's like this [ __ ] is crazy none
of this [ __ ] makes sense like I think I
think like and even like certain [ __ ]
like the like you know um when you guys
had that uh what's what's the comedian's
name from La who said he was into the
trans women and you guys they're posting
that's my guide if you guys brought the
girl on the next episode that [ __ ] is
hilarious but it's also like Ultra
Progressive if you really think of like
bringing somebody from that community on
in a normal situation yeah it kind of
like you know I think we we only see
those kind of people in like memes yeah
or like in like this like really
extremely like weird woke way and like I
just thought it was like the best way to
normalize any group of people or any
person is to treat them normally and
just talk to them talk to them normally
that's the whole point right so if we
have a conversation with a trans woman
and then we make some jokes but we have
fun and we learn and you're gonna make a
joke with a straight woman you're gonna
make a joke with everybody that's what
you're gonna do oh yeah that's what it
is equal opportunity offenders and then
I feel like hey now I think a lot of
people walked away from that like oh I
look at this differently yeah for sure
yeah for sure when you guys went to
Florida
um okay I think we're talking a little
bit off camera but how how uh because
that that was a moment for sure you guys
did the open Line Andrew did open her up
with jelly roll which was [ __ ]
hilarious it was amazing but it was
definitely probably at that time a
pretty hard contrast to New York policy
wise DeSantis had that [ __ ] booming we
loved it too yeah we [ __ ] because I
gave everybody coven I got right right
right show in Atlantic City he [ __ ]
coveted the covet of America and then I
get I'll be there November 4th and uh
then I gave it to everybody so the
upside as miserable as that was is now
we're all immune we got the answer
everybody's got it yeah and we're
sitting in New York where everything is
shut down the middle of winter I didn't
I had actually just convinced my wife to
move from Jersey back to the city
because prices were so low yeah but then
Andrew sends a text and he's like we
can't this city sucks right now let's go
to Miami and I had just paid a little
bit of money and I was like this is
going to be such a thing but my wife was
like [ __ ] yeah let's go to Miami [ __ ]
yeah we got the antibodies everything is
open I was miserable in covid dude
without stand-up I I hate these guys who
are like I can't live without stand-up
but I really really did in covet I was
right [ __ ] dude you felt that I'm
depressed I've never been depressed
until that right it was really [ __ ]
down awful place and then a lot of
weirdos like Shaman comedians who are
still doing shows I'm like what the [ __ ]
yeah yeah and even the shows were
uncomfortable because it was covered
everything is spaced out comedy's so
much about laughter being contagious
that's why we pack you it's like an Open
Table in the middle it was every other
table was open like 15 feet between so
it's like
this is a weird thing but so much of
Comedy is just is D is are people around
you laughing then I feel more
comfortable laughing yeah for sure it's
a community thing yeah because you don't
ever be watching a movie and you're
laughing and nobody else is you know my
bad yeah I missed it for sure
um so with the show sucked and it was
2020 the election everything was so
tense George Floyd like it was just like
a bad time to do comedy spaced out it
wasn't fun and then Florida we go there
it's sunshine it's open
everybody's just happy you're getting
vitamin D you're eating out you're like
living a life it was the best dude yeah
I wanted to stay there so badly do you
guys think you guys would ever leave New
York I mean obviously you got the new
studio eventually I am doing everything
I can to make sure that to make us leave
New York I'm just one man you're just
one but this is my movement yo you guys
had taken some time off I think when uh
Andrew went on his vacation but you guys
had just dropped all these heated
interviews like [ __ ] back to back to
back yeah it was like you know it was a
couple of months ago it was crazy I
missed most of them because my my
honeymoon didn't match with his and I
was like [ __ ] dude because my wife had
school so I was like this is what has
there ever been an interview for you
where you were like a little nervous or
you were like that you looked forward to
the most when you knew before the most
Michael Irvin Cowboy fan yeah he was my
favorite cowboy when I was a kid it was
Emmett but then as I grew up I was like
no I love this guy yeah he's got the
passion he plays with the heart he's got
like I love this [ __ ] guy yeah a
little flawed and then he was the best
dude loves a cocaine yeah I loved
hopefully yeah but uh he was so funny
dog he came and immediately started
making fun of our studio like it wasn't
even on camera right right right then he
went and took a [ __ ] in the public
bathroom it was just like and then he's
complaining about this the bathroom it
was just so funny the whole time people
don't understand how much funnier he is
ESPN oh yeah he's on the Pod he's
hilarious right now I remember yeah I'm
dying to do a podcast with Michael Irvin
yeah like I think people need to see
that 3D dimensional mic as opposed to
just football mike yeah almost like he
should do a [ __ ] podcast and I feel
like every athlete has one 100 you
should just do like 12 a year where you
just like yo this is the story from 1991
when I had a six some was sunny which is
strippers and eight ball cocaine if you
watch that episode he talks about going
out with uh Mike Tyson and taking Tio
out with him and T.O was like a still
shy little guy right and it's like a
yeah he's got story after story he's so
funny yeah you guys you guys have done
Tyson too right no no I'd love to I'd be
terrified but I would love that yeah
yeah yeah yeah shout out to Tyson
Tyson's a wild guy man very intense hey
we gotta stop the interview real quick
tell you about our partners at my bookie
that's right salute to the family at my
bookie all right it is so much action to
get in on right now in sports we got the
playoffs in baseball we got NFL action
every Sunday and NBA season is upon us
yes if you want to get in on the action
and make some of this money with me I'd
be gambling all damn day
I might have a problem with that being
said go to my bookie right now when you
sign up use the promo code bootleg and
they will match your deposit all right
that's right your first deposit when you
sign up with a new account when you use
that promo code bootleg they're gonna
match it all right that means if you put
in 500 bucks you get another 500 for
free to gamble with yeah all right I'm
loving uh some of the Futures too uh I
love the over on wins for the Sacramento
Kings and the NBA season coming up I
think they're going to have a good year
I'll also beta over on the Phoenix Suns
they're gonna have more than 52 and a
half wins what are we talking about plus
NFL action every Sunday let's get this
money go to my bookie right now sign up
with that promo code bootleg all right
when you do that they're matching your
first deposit off the rip no matter how
big or small let's run that [ __ ] up go
to my bookie right now use that promo
code bootleg and get your first deposit
matched free money to gamble with with
my bookie let's get back to the
interview I was I was about to say is
there that is that one of the ones that
you like obviously I'm sure if you had
your wishlist who would be on dream
guest probably Charles Barkley that
would be crazy I love that guy he's
hilarious he doesn't give a [ __ ] he
would fit right in the couch he don't
give a [ __ ] about every like the other
day they had the the uh the first night
of the season they had a they were just
putting players up on the board and
having him guess what team they were on
and he got like zero out of ten yeah
yeah
he was like I don't know the Kings
he can and he missed everyone yeah he
never gets him yeah it was it was so
funny dude uh what are your man I I
would assume you're are you a Kanye West
fan musically obviously in terms of just
like his discography as a as a hip-hop
guy he's amazing he's a genius I think
he's one of the most you know probably
greater discographies in rap history
yeah I don't know enough about music to
really appreciate it I know he's great
but like Alex obviously got an ear and
of course and he was like you don't
understand how Innovative every
everything he does is sonically 100 and
that makes sense and I buy I do love his
music but uh
I will say I started to think he was
this is well before any of this [ __ ] I
was like to be honest at least he's
funny now uh I you know it's still
[ __ ] up what he's saying but at least
it's funny but like I felt like he
became everything he said he wasn't
gonna become
around about the time of graduation he
started to really shift into that makes
sense you're becoming everything you
said you wouldn't be in College Dropout
yeah it was kind of like a I think I
think his mom passed away around the
time like 808 so yeah that makes sense
man it's crazy because like
it's like if you like I watched the
drink did you watch the dream Champs
interview I watched like an hour and a
half yeah that's about what I watched
yeah but like his bigger points are so
like okay dude like instead of being an
anti-semitic crazy person all you got to
do is say hey shout out to the Jewish
people they they are on to something
that's how I've always felt and I'm not
saying that the product is gonna [ __ ]
with me anyway so I'm not saying this to
get a deal but I've always as a minority
said that's what every minority she says
they want to do and then they never pull
it off let's stick together let's
support our own let's support educated
together financial literacy yeah start
our own company so it's like yo you
could say that without [ __ ] on like
I don't even know how many people are in
his personal life that are Jewish I know
his personal trainer was like it's just
like it's it's it's kind of like
watching a [ __ ] up car crash and your
childhood heroes in it and you're like
oh so I got the best Insight from my
friend he's a very funny comic his name
is Matt pavich but he struggles with
bipolar disorder really talented kid and
I've been with him when he's on those
manic episodes and it's like intense and
uncomfortable and I was asking him I was
like this is a manic episode right he's
like textbook and then he goes I don't
know if this is actually like a
scientific thing but I know for me when
I'm having a Manning episode I love
getting a rise out of people and I will
say anything to get a rise out of him
right I'll say the most [ __ ] up
horrendous things did you just bust out
Oh I thought you farted crazy though you
farted bro I'm like what the [ __ ] bro
anyway this guy got a great beard to be
off camera why are you looking that good
for it I came here in joggers no but
you're so it makes sense that you're
just gonna say [ __ ] like Defcon 3 or
whatever if you're having an episode
you're just trying to get a rise out and
it's almost like every time you get the
rise it's like it's almost like yeah and
he's like I don't know why but my friend
was telling me I don't know why but I
love it I've said [ __ ] up things that
like to my family and they thought
that's how I really felt and it's like
no I was just having an episode and I
loved getting that emotion out of you so
I really think that's what's happening
and we're all yo I'm not like
um I don't want to be too whatever but
the idea that you're either just crazy
or not crazy I don't think is a thing
you can't agree be not crazy and have
bipolar disorder and I think if we keep
doing this is he crazy is he not crazy
Connie's gonna be like I'm not crazy
it's not crazy but you do have bipolar
disorder you might be having an episode
he still probably won't listen but it's
a way better chance and if you say now
you're crazy he's also like extremely
narcissistic like he's truly probably
like he believes he's you know
I mean he always says that I am I am the
I am Michael pick one Jordan Jacqueline
all right dude yeah we get it yeah that
was that was actually a fire line it was
it was it was a fire line the Pierce
mortgage shoes so I don't know if you
saw the clips son why does he change his
voice you notice how much Kanye code
switches yeah he's on drink Champs he's
different and then his voice all of a
sudden his voice gets a little bit
higher and you have to understand uh
yeah it's whatever it's crazy it's crazy
it's gross dude it's crazy does he talk
like that to Kim I don't know Paul
Kardashian family
you ever in any relationship with Pete
Davidson oh yeah yeah Pete is I've known
Pete since he was like 15 not super well
right but always seen him I always told
him hey man you're a funny kid you're a
good kid right and I still feel that way
he's a good kid who just happens to be
great at getting [ __ ] well I got a
problem with this man all time for sure
all time yo yeah who dislikes this guy
you're jealous no it's crazy it's like
when you think of his Hit List it's like
it's like Leonardo DiCaprio it's like
Pete Davidson I mean yeah but Leonardo
DiCaprio no disrespected people it's
really really rich did Titanic and it's
a much more beautiful looking than Pete
Davidson no disrespect yeah sure I'm not
even oh yeah this guy's like been a
heartthrob since he was 17. yeah oh yeah
sure I'll [ __ ] Leonardo DiCaprio why not
but I'm not I'm saying Leonardo DiCaprio
I remember him slaying with women
after Titanic the highest grossing movie
of all time where he is the iconic
heartthrob quintessential everyone like
he better be getting [ __ ] after that
yeah Pete is just out here Peach is the
guy from SNS guy on SNL looking gangly
every once in a while terrible tattoo
yeah I just asked some funny ass rants
but like no I don't know girls that will
look at a rant and be like I gotta [ __ ]
the guy doing the rant on the weekend
and like we're talking like Kim
Kardashian
uh Ariana Grande like yeah yeah it's
like it's the greatest list in history
quite possibly no there's somebody else
I'm I mean let's see Jeter had a Jeter
jeters is nuts Pete Davidson is arguably
as good as Jeter and that's crazy yeah
crazy it's crazy man he must he must be
a real cocksman that guy yeah God bless
him I mean just something
um talk about just like what's next for
flagrant I always you know I I I always
like have this thing in my head where
I'm like man I would love if some of my
favorite podcasters comedians because we
always me and my boys are always talking
about how like good comedies are just
dead like I can't think of the last like
classic that's a [ __ ] that is
actually it's crazy you bring it up
because Andrews he gets like these Grand
obsessions which are good right so
beautiful thing because he pulls it off
right now it is I want us to make a
movie yeah dude because there's no more
funny movies yeah like I I can't think
of the last like
it's been at least 10 years since like
there was like a super classic yeah I
mean like girls trip was cool
um yeah Tiffany haddish
[ __ ] destroyed that movie it was such
a great movie I haven't seen that's one
of the greatest comedic performances
I've ever seen in a movie and people act
like that movie would have been good
without her it would have sucked dick
without Tiffany yeah that's probably the
last great it was like that and
bridesmaids like but like before that
what are we really talking about this is
great I Remember Loving wedding crashes
in college but that's like for weddings
that's what I mean like even if you go
back like I think it's probably like
hangover hangover super bad it's
destroyed it was probably super bad
right yeah if you really think about
like the last like yo classic comedy
yeah like Step Brothers Step Brothers
[ __ ] Banger Step Brothers all the
Judd Apatow joints like I just feel like
there's such a huge
just gaping whole Paws for somebody to
come through and [ __ ] put their face
in yeah yeah [ __ ] right like the
dudes from Workaholics tried to do it on
that Netflix movie but that [ __ ] was
kind of whatever yeah but I feel like if
like you guys did a movie or if you guys
could and just put all the [ __ ] sick
comedians in it like [ __ ] have Tim
Dillon play the fat funny guy you know
yeah yeah yeah yeah no that's that's the
thing that Andrew is currently like
obsessed with and yo we watched this
show you ever seen the offer I have not
heard I've heard of it though I haven't
seen it though um it's a great it's a
fun show it's it's all in Paramount plus
it's just it's about the making of The
Godfather
you don't realize like how much [ __ ] had
to happen for them the only thing I'm on
Paramount plus four is [ __ ]
Yellowstone but I I gotta watch it check
it out it's super fun again there's
little cheesy moments but it's just fun
and
there's a scene that makes him say I
want to do movies the main character
who's like a he executive produces The
Godfather right and he leaves the
theater and he's like you don't get this
experience anywhere else he's like
sitting in a theater and this is
backward theaters were like theaters but
still that's true man as great as
YouTube is yeah it's hard to make you
feel that way nothing matches a movie
and I remember watching that and then
Andrew was talking about this
immediately like right around the same
time I was like I want to do a movie
I'll do a movie and I'm not as obsessed
as him but I'm like yo he's right man we
can create a feeling a [ __ ] Euphoria
group shared Euphoria YouTube I'm here
oh I'm here it's just me maybe one or
two other people 200 people sharing a
thing it's the closest thing you can get
to a live stand-up show no for sure or a
concert yeah yeah and like I think just
somebody has to do it if it's y'all if
it's you know have Joe Rogan just
bankroll that [ __ ] yeah that
might be the movie that might be the
move yeah it just feels like man like I
don't know if it's uh uh something that
goes to theaters or not I don't know if
it's like hey we dropped a movie it's on
Amazon Prime go run that [ __ ] up or
Netflix bought the movie or whatever it
is but it just feels like yo somebody
has to step in and if and you guys have
done so many things to kind of Kick the
doors down in general just being
independent you feel like making a movie
would be you know why they don't do as
many and this might be something to try
to figure out again the team that yeah
we got a good team that could figure it
out but the problem with comedy
financing is comedy doesn't translate
internationally and international sales
are so important to movie yeah to the
studios now that's why the Avengers will
throw any money at it because
internationally everyone will watch it
comedy people aren't going to watch this
internationally most likely well also
yeah because comedy is different and
culturally yeah like the jokes that
might work here aren't going to work in
China yeah they just don't they don't
know what the [ __ ] you're talking about
yeah they're like huh yeah no that's
real so it's almost harder to even get
Studios behind it so it's like what are
we doing like yeah it's it's sad though
because [ __ ] man
I I really think like the best comedy
[ __ ] is through podcasts or like series
like TV series yeah we need a good
comedy movie though we really haven't
had a great one yeah it's been a while
man yeah 100 I was about to say
Eastbound and Down but that was a TV
show TV show
candy [ __ ] Powers man righteous
gemstones just yo that dude Danny
McBride just plays the same he just
plays Kenny Powers in everything and he
kills it he's [ __ ] amazing his name
is Kenny Powers not Danny McBride for
real for real dude it's crazy man
um what would you say
um was something that you kind of uh
you know
being around Andrew as long as when did
you guys first meet oh oh wait oh wait
he was like the four are you in La at
that time yeah I just moved to New York
okay he's one of the first guys I met we
were both doing this Hood room in
Brooklyn the show got canceled and I
remember back then I didn't know like
the skinny jeans was like fashion so I
was like look at this [ __ ] door
coming up here in skinny jeans in a
[ __ ] Mohawk and then I was like but
he's doing a hood room in Brooklyn right
guy can't be some he can't be like a
dork for real right he's got to be funny
so we shook hands and then he was he
asked me if I wanted to ride back to the
show because the show got canceled right
back to the city to Manhattan and he was
in a minivan which was also so funny but
he and I just started talking about
comedy we had like the exact same taste
yeah and I'm in New York so I'm dying
for people to hang out with but we kind
of went our separate ways and then every
once in a while I would go by the
Village Lantern and just hang out with
him and his crew and I kind of got along
with him well but I would still go do
shows and like [ __ ] in the Bronx or
wherever and bomb non-stop but uh I
remember I was about to leave New York
and I was like yo I always have fun with
these guys over here let me hang out for
here I was gonna give you like one more
month let me hang out here see if I can
make some friends because New York at
the time super PC comedy or super Hood
comedy right and I'm not like one or the
other yeah I'm not either so I was like
let me me just hang out with these guys
and then I found he and I like not only
had the same taste in comedy we thought
on a very similar wavelength and we
could have conversations at about you
know I I what I thought was a pretty
high level I don't know guys or not but
of course you know and then bits we were
we wanted to do comedy the same way
which is I wanted to be a little
divisive I want a challenge with I think
I want to go at this PC [ __ ] and so it
just became and then we're both super
loyal and then from there just built
into it that's important man yeah you
guys all seem like you know I mean I
think it's dope like anything you guys
do like everyone's supporting or
involved in yeah you know whether it's
like Alex opening up his podcast Studio
or you know obviously you're you're
special uh everyone's helping out with
the Netflix thing thank you it's
definitely dope to see man the one thing
I've said to Andrew and I think this and
I hope this continues and I think it's
been the key to how we've kept growing
and not had too much [ __ ] we had little
things here and there but the main thing
was uh we need to put the friendship
over the podcast right it cannot ever be
how much money this makes me right if it
ever becomes this will cost me my
friendship with Andrew I have to walk
right and that's a you know as the money
gets bigger that's the thing that feels
a lot heavier right when the lifestyle
increases and you're like [ __ ] I don't
know how I'm gonna figure it out but I
have to figure it out because like this
can't cost me my friendship right so
yeah hey what up y'all bootleg cab here
uh we got to interrupt the interview and
tell you about our family at Blue Chew
look if you go to bluetooth.com right
now use the promo code bootleg to sign
up and you will get your first month of
blue chew for free that's right they're
going to give you the first month of
blue chew for free all you got to do is
pay five dollars in shipping and you're
gonna get delivered right to your door
some great [ __ ] for your dick let me
tell you what it is all right if you're
dealing with erectile dysfunction if
you're dealing with any sort of stress
and you just need an extra little uh you
know a little performance enhancer if
you will all right for you Johnson down
there all you got to do is go to
Bluetooth uh and use that promo code
bootleg and it's coming straight to your
door the same active ingredient as
Viagra as Cialis and then the new mint
chewable breaking news there is a new
mint chewable that blue shoe has just
introduced to the marketplace and it has
the same active ingredient as Levitra
and stackson I'm gonna try to tell you
about this active ingredient it's VAR
denafil
yeah I [ __ ] that up but
try it out supposed to be a little more
potent than a normal blue shoe whatever
you need regular blue chew the new mint
chewable whatever it is you're gonna
knock it out the [ __ ] Park all right
look Barry Bonds needed a little
performance enhancing when he uh hit 73
home runs back in the day he holds the
record still you might need a little
performance enhancement in the bedroom
your lady will think you your wife will
thank you your boyfriend will thank you
whatever the [ __ ] you're into we're not
judging over here at the Boolean cat
podcast but I am judging you if you
don't go to Bluetooth right now and sign
up with that promo code bootleg and get
a month for free try it out it's
literally free all right let's get back
to the interview and you guys are
killing on the patreon [ __ ] is crazy yo
thank you man yeah that's uh that was we
started that because I was [ __ ] broke
I think I subscribed to the patreon I
don't know maybe two years ago because I
I don't know I was just like curious
because I never heard of it but I heard
you guys talking I was like what the
[ __ ] is this patreon [ __ ] I think when I
subscribed you could see like how many
people you guys had on the pill I was
like what the [ __ ] yeah yeah and then I
started doing the math in my head and
I'm like oh these guys are rich yeah and
that was again started because I was
legitimately like I had no I probably
made I'm not bullshitting probably made
six thousand dollars total in 2018. wow
I was going broke we've been doing the
podcast the whole time six thousand
dollars for the total total if I'm lucky
I had savings because 2017 went pretty
well I was on like six MTV shows right
so you have some money in the bank
Series yeah and I and then one by one
everything starts getting canceled and
now getting picked up and you keep
thinking I'm gonna be okay I got all
this other stuff right and then each one
and then I'm left with nothing and I'm
trying to survive and I'm talking to
Andrew softly about this patreon thing
because I think our fans would [ __ ] with
it yeah and we weren't big at the time
but uh I was talking about other
podcasts that were like killing it and
then their listen trip was way bigger
and he was like dude I don't know if it
makes sense finally I was so broke I
literally said I go I'm literally
pleading with you at this point can we
please do please can we start the
patreon and he was like fine and then he
marketed it so brilliantly and like
really want to build a community aspect
of the Pod through it and I think that
helped so much but yeah it just became
this thing helped fund a lot of stuff
would you guys ever do like flagrant
live
with the live show we have to figure out
right for me I would and Andrew for
Andrew I'm asking him to split money
with me when he could go he's a huge
draw yeah yeah on his own of course and
for me I felt like I didn't get to do
stand up like for whatever reason the
industry has never liked me and that's
fine I'm not mad about it but I didn't
get to like go headline clubs until
basically right before coven right and
then obviously covet shut everything
down so now once I started doing an hour
five times a weekend I felt like I grew
so much right and I was never that
confident in stand up before it's
because I'm doing it now I look back
it's like because I'm doing comedy 15
minutes at a time at a club and I'm done
right and I'm looking at all these peers
of mine who are doing five hours a
weekend and they're ahead of me and I'm
getting in my head about it now I felt
like now I feel like yo let's go whoever
wants I'm as good as anybody out there
which is a really cool place to be it's
a nice place to be man when you get when
you feel like you're in your bag like
that I feel like I'm in my I feel like
I'm in my [ __ ] bag yeah so the live
podcast I'll do it I'm with it but right
now my my obsession is kind of catching
up yeah catching up to what what
happened yeah you got a little taste of
it before covert hit yeah yeah yeah and
even just letting [ __ ] like I
really feel like now [ __ ] need
to know like come see the show I I
promise even if you don't like me you
can't say I'm not good at it yeah you're
gonna say he's good at I might thought
he was a [ __ ] a shrimp whatever
again like me but you just objectively
he's good at this [ __ ] uh who is in your
like uh give me your Mount Rushmore
comedians all time
Patrice uh uh yep yep yep uh I don't
like saying it because he's so annoying
now but Chappelle
I just just stop crying dude I don't
mind the trans jokes you know what it is
with Chappelle it's like to me he's like
probably my personal favorite of all
time like he's probably my girlfriend
it's hard because you're just yeah but
it's like it's like every time I see him
now it's like I'm not sure if I'm
watching comedy as much as I'm watching
like some sort of like Ted talk you know
what I'm saying son yeah and well I
don't mind the Ted Talk dog he did do
you remember bird Revelation is the one
in the upstairs of The Comedy Store he
actually was there you were there I was
there it was unfucking believable yeah I
was there unbelievable I was dying yeah
me and my wife are I think we're like
because they they took footage from I
think like five different filmings or
whatever it was beautiful by the way
thank you both of us really outkicked
our coverage yeah we did we did man yeah
um yeah so we uh yeah I think cyphus
sound somehow hooked me up and we ended
up being like right in the front row or
second row of of Chappelle Netflix
filming it was [ __ ] wild but he
killed it but I almost feel like that
was kind of the last time I saw him do
stand-up where I was just like [ __ ] this
and I haven't seen him live I know he's
been doing a lot of live [ __ ] but like
yeah I feel like uh some of my favorites
have been disappointed me lately I
wasn't crazy about Katt Williams latest
he I'm I just see like interviews of him
and stuff and it's like it's a sad I
hope this doesn't happen to me
the greatest thing about Jay-Z is he
doesn't [ __ ] on the generations beneath
him true little things here and there
with the money to your ear yeah maybe
like you know the odd death auto tune
but you know yeah yeah but I I think
like uh yeah like I even I even like I
like Bill Burr's new special but maybe I
saw him do it in LA a few times so it
didn't hit as much because I was like
I've seen I saw him [ __ ] you know what
Bill Burr might be the goat he might I
might need to switch it to Bill Burr
because here's what I see man when I was
watching live at Red Rocks I watched I I
watched the first like 40 30 40 minutes
and I was like yo the the consistency of
this guy is yeah it's great parallel
yeah I had seen him so much
um in La like I saw him in those parking
lots like me and my wife that's like our
main date night thing we'll go to The
Comedy Store or if there's uh somebody I
like I'll be like oh we'll buy tickets
to go watch Bill Burr in a parking lot
in L.A yeah and so I just felt like I
saw 90 of his [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah so and
same thing with Tim Dylan like I saw Tim
Dylan special I feel like five times in
The Comedy Store sure it was like I know
what the punch line is so when I watch
it on and I think he kind of recognized
that too because I heard him talking
about it like I've been doing this hour
for so long right yeah there's so much
covered [ __ ] yeah you know who actually
I [ __ ] with
I never really gave them like too much
of a chance because I always just
Associated this dude with the Chelsea
Handler show but Joe Coy Jo koi is a
beast dude his new stand-up is [ __ ]
hot he's a beast he does this bit about
dudes who are on those ventilators to go
to sleep yeah the CPAC [ __ ] he's like
you look like a ghost is [ __ ] you in
the mouth
okay so you got Patrice you got
Chappelle Burr
here's the thing Chappelle might need to
get bumped because okay I can't not put
Russell Peters on there obviously for
them that's a great Mount Rushmore but
then how do you not put Pryor on there
would you say priors a little bit before
your time though priors a little bit
before my time but I appreciated how
good prior was Eddie Murphy was the
first stand of I remember [ __ ] dying
at was the family Barbecue right I
remember me and my homies listening
crying laughing at an audio CD and I was
like yo those were the days audio can
make you laugh this hard I didn't know I
saw bring the pain I love bring the pain
Rock was my idol for so many years Chris
Rock I think was my favorite uh for a
long time too yeah yeah bigger and
Blacker and just like yeah the crazy
[ __ ] about bigger and Blacker is it's
like a year after bringing the pain so
to have that much hate back to back is
nuts and I think it might have been
better I think if like I wish Bernie
when he like hit his stride as like a
superstar I wish he would have did more
[ __ ] I know he had the show and that was
amazing for him the Def Jam [ __ ] he had
the obviously we go back to the Def Jam
[ __ ] obviously Kings of comics he's a
comedy dude he murdered everybody and
everybody killed it on that but he
murdered everybody
the rumor maybe I'm speaking out a turn
but the rumor is it was supposed to be
Steve Harvey headlining right but nobody
could follow Bernie yeah so he Barney
with middle Steve Harvey would struggle
so they were like yo good deal hugely on
here Steve you host that rounds out the
show and but nobody that's why they put
Bernie at the end he wasn't supposed to
headline but they were like nobody can
follow him nobody can [ __ ] with this
guys
son unbelievable uh all right so Russell
Peters
all right let's let's try it let's go
like Mount Rushmore because I think
billboard and this is your Mount
Rushmore my Mount Rushmore is Patrice
Burr
Russell
rocker Chappelle okay I'm not sure I
think Eileen Chapel yeah uh I think the
actual like the greatest yeah I would
push Burr off because I think he might
be the best but he didn't like change
comedy so it would be I think Patrice uh
prior uh Chappelle
and I don't know the fourth maybe like a
Lenny Bruce or some [ __ ] because we just
didn't I like George Carlin too Carlin
Carlin was a beast man yeah yeah yeah
when my when I was a kid my dad used to
always listen to his CDs and [ __ ] you
know what's crazy about Carlin if you uh
there's a documentary on having HBO I
didn't know this he was like a clean 50s
goofy comic right and then it was the
guy he became it was because of an acid
trip wow he took acid and he was like
I'm a fraud nothing is real none of this
is real so he was like on some Bill
Cosby [ __ ] kind of prior to doing assets
yeah I like this Goofy stuff like 50s
and what comedy was in 50s to be on TV
what he was making money but he hated it
then he just yeah he was doing it to
feed his family but then he had an acid
trip and I was like I'm a [ __ ] fraud
and then to change everything that's
wild have you ever done acid or anything
no I've only psycho I've been high twice
once with Joe Rogan yeah oh yeah you
guys it's the first time I ever smoked
weed and then last week because my wife
will get high every once in a while and
I always felt because I was always like
no I don't do that right right right and
I felt bad I was like I can't get high
with Rogan and then never get high with
my wife yeah yeah so we took an edible
that was a fun time dude we had fun so
you gotta watch yourself on the Edibles
man we
if you take a little bit too much you
might have the worst night of your life
oh dude I had a gummy a who's wax gummy
back in the day and I just took the
whole thing yeah and I was sick I
wouldn't even hide I woke up in the
middle of the night I just like took it
and went to sleep in the middle of the
night room was spinning and I couldn't
figure out what's going on and then I
realized it's the edible and then the
next day on the plane go flying back I
was [ __ ] miserable never shrooms or
nothing no but I'm interested in shrooms
I don't want to do I'm I'm okay with
natural stuff I think right I'm open to
shrooms done weed I think I might even
do like Ayahuasca I want to do that [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah but that [ __ ] is like I'm
almost scared of like how like what I'm
gonna be confronted with because it's
like supposed to be like life changing
yeah yeah you gotta go be with a shaman
it's like two days
yeah like who knows how the [ __ ] I'm
gonna be after I do Ayahuasca like I
might maybe I divorced my wife or
something I don't know no no come on
um hey what up y'all gotta stop the
interview to tell you about our family
at Odd Socks that's right go to
oddsoxofficial.com right now use the
promo code bootleg that's right bootleg
you will save 20 off at checkout now
listen we know that they have amazing
socks these are sour patch kids socks
these are hot Cheeto socks
Half Baked you know what I'm saying and
uh you know for those that like Snapple
so much so that you would wear socks
with snapple's logo on them and all my
Naruto fans they have the Naruto but
let's bust these boys out you know they
they got the underwear and the underwear
are crazy love the draws what do we have
here
oh oh we have we have Hey Arnold
underwear
these are [ __ ] amazing Jesus I'm
gonna wear these you know why I'm gonna
wear those oh because I have
Hey Arnold socks on you see what I did
there yeah that's right
we out here represent Odd Socks the most
comfortable socks in the world I promise
you if you get your Odd Socks Basics
like these these are the basics right
those are uh I mean you're not gonna get
any better than that you know what I
mean the odd Sox Basics are incredible
all right so uh that's my favorite I'm
always wearing a black or white pair of
Odd Socks Basics but uh don't like
listen to me try them out for yourself
go to oddsoxofficial.com use the promo
code bootleg save 20 off at checkout and
they got some new [ __ ] coming at the top
of the Year hmm I would say go to their
Instagram at oddsocks official
and just look at some of the shoes that
uh the owner's wearing in some of the
videos they may or may not be having
some slides coming out I don't know I
cannot confirm nor disconfirm but you
know they did put them on their
Instagram for a reason like a little
tidbit little little crumbs to what's
coming next year
plus they just dropped their monster
socks which I don't have any of those
here but it is Halloween season so go
[ __ ] with those you already know man odd
Sox official go [ __ ] with them on
Instagram go to oddsoxofficial.com and
use the promo code bootleg save 20 off a
checkout and when you do that you
support us you support the whole crew
over here at the bootlegate podcast so
let's get back to the interview and uh
what other one is DMT natural yes
because that seems like a [ __ ] party
so DMT there's you have to get it the
natural way there's a synthetic DMT and
then there's like pens that is like the
synthetic like you vape DMT which is now
you're supposed to do it you're supposed
to get the real [ __ ] you're supposed to
freebase it like it's crack
and yeah from what I hear I mean I I got
close friends who sell that [ __ ] and do
it and they're very much like yo man
there's only one way to do it because
there's people who give you a panda like
it's a DNT pen and my friend did that
yeah you don't want to do that you want
to freebase it you want to get full
Pookie from [ __ ] you gotta you got it
that's what I mean at least the people
who I know who are really like into that
[ __ ] they're like there's you have to
freebase it you have to smoke it like
like that's the only way to go and then
what do they say happens just you're
gone 20 minutes
it's only 20 minutes
my I had a homie who told me he did DMT
and during his trip
he it was it felt like about six months
yeah he said he got a job met a girl
like [ __ ] lived a six-month life
and then woke up in only like 18 minutes
had passed that's amazing it's also
[ __ ] scary as [ __ ]
that's amazing imagine like you you hit
something and you you just go away and
you live like six months of life and
then you wake up and you're like what
it's like some [ __ ] straight out of the
movies but you have to yeah from what I
hear I mean I like mushrooms I do I do
shrooms a lot I was shrooming hard last
night how was that it's great I have a
gummy company that I'm a part of so I
can hook you up with some gummies
they're gravy maybe you just micro dose
oh okay you could just take like one and
like go work out like some people use
them as pre-workouts which is cool what
is it what does it do
um it just depends on how much you eat
so if you were to take one it makes you
a little bit more focused it kind of
just
it kind of makes everything a little bit
more realistic a little more HD
if you the more you eat I would say the
more you like start to really kind of
get Ultra lost in your yeah how much do
I got to take to get [ __ ] smacked I
was just not too high eat a whole bag
well that seems crazy it's an eighth
okay the whole bag of the gummies you
could do six ounces
it's no no they're they're pretty
properly dosed so it's 12 pieces and the
bags of eighth so if you really want to
get smacked do six and you'll you'll be
able to that's a nice good high nothing
crazy yeah nothing crazy yeah I mean it
also it also depends on what you ate for
the day
and if you have like an empty you want
to eat them on an empty stomach really
yeah because then you get the real full
like
you really feel it just depends on what
you're trying to get into man
you know if you have like a [ __ ] real
heavy dinner
there you might need to eat more because
they won't hit as hard because you got
so much [ __ ] soaking up the psilocybin
I'm look I'm gonna try to do this with
my wife she's scared of it but we need a
Sherpa I don't know what that is
somebody's so big I just found it
somebody's sober just making sure you're
not funny no no no no no no y'all be all
right unless yeah you sound like you
guys are gonna [ __ ] commit suicide on
accident or anything yeah okay yeah
you'll be fine what about right now uh
you gave me your Mount Rushmore who are
the funniest comedians alive right now
Bill Burr is number one okay uh I I
think Rogan is up there
um
Andrew obviously yeah I'm putting myself
in that [ __ ] list I don't care love
it
I'm trying to think who am I watching
right now that I'm like bro that's
[ __ ] crazy
yeah I think uh it's kind of hard for me
to answer because I just feel like
I just watched I'm like fans of podcasts
as much as I am stand up so it's like
um
I think Tim Dylan's so [ __ ] hilarious
I could just watch him talk he's such a
starter you can just watch him talk for
like an hour about anything and I'm just
like I'm just dying yeah that's his he's
a gifted just talker yeah like the fact
he could do that like with with no I
mean obviously he had his producer but
with no co-host or anything he's just
[ __ ] rambling about the Kardashians
or [ __ ] Russia like yo I want to know
what Tim Dylan has to say about
geopolitics yeah because it's so
entertaining I haven't heard the new
hour from Rogan but I heard somebody was
telling me he's like e this is the best
he's been in a while because he was he
said I don't want to get this money and
go to Austin and become some rich like
lazy attitude right right so he's been
in the [ __ ] lab so no he's uh no he's
I always see him and like he's doing
Vulcan and [ __ ] yeah do you feel like
he's a little underrated because he's so
polarizing for some reason like I feel
like maybe people don't give him as much
respect for like I think
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and I mean the
guy changed that we're all doing
podcasts because of Joe Rogan of course
yeah he changed the whole game man so I
think in that sense a lot of people just
hate now some people who love them are
going to overrate him so maybe oh yeah
like my cousin my cousin's entire life
his opinion on everything in the world
is formed based on whatever Joe Rogan is
saying which is crazy because Joe
Rogan's whole thing is bringing on
everybody then all of a sudden he hits
me he's like hey
I know you've been supporting Bernie
Sanders for a long time I saw him on Joe
Rogan not a bad guy
he's like I think we might have had him
all wrong and I'm like
yeah dude
yeah
yo people are such losers man it's so
crazy God there's so many people out
there just it's embarrassing figures for
you it's like dude you gotta have four
of your own thoughts man yeah you got a
four-year-old thoughts you can't just
dive it like it sucks too because
unfortunately nowadays it's the heart
it's harder than ever to form your own
thoughts because whatever you think
they're just gonna keep feeding you more
of that [ __ ] man is that Herschel Walker
might win this election
ain't that crazy I've seen this man get
CTE I'm a Cowboy fan would you would you
vote for him just based on the cowboys
history
clearly he's clearly guys he was bipolar
years ago beat the Shadows why decades
ago like I knew all this it's crazy and
he might be
I'm not surprised though I root for him
if he was fighting MMA you remember we
fought MMA I was very happy he beat the
[ __ ] out of that guy I don't remember
that I remember he did it but I don't
remember if he won or no he won he
kicked the [ __ ] out of the guy I think
one of those that was like one of the
more lopsided wild trades I think in
football history yeah it built the
cowboy Dynasty yeah this guy did
everything for me as a sports fan but
you got too much brain damage to be I
don't care what your politics are if you
played professional contact Manny
Pacquiao shouldn't be no [ __ ]
Congressman no no I don't care no the
Philippines are [ __ ] crazy like my
boy is Filipino and he goes he goes
there all the time he's like yo if you
if you get caught with weed they put you
in prison
like prison like the [ __ ] president
of the Philippines is like a crazy
person there's some wild laws out there
dude I heard in Thailand if you make fun
of the king or the Emperor or whatever
that's you're [ __ ] you're [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] by a [ __ ] for sure yeah
shut up yeah anyway listen man uh go
watch the podcast going crazy yeah man
we're doing you guys are [ __ ] killing
it thank you man thank you it's crazy go
to the patreon hopefully a new special
maybe top of the year-ish I don't have a
timeline but just come see me live and I
think you'll enjoy it and then we're
gonna we're gonna cook up something and
I want it to be [ __ ] good I don't
want to take too long but right I'm
gonna cook up some maybe it'd just be a
lot of Clips I don't know but I feel
like I got when you're doing the like
touring right
are you still hitting like local clubs
here to like work on [ __ ] or are you
just working on everything on the road
right now because there's so much
podcast prep my wife rode no [ __ ]
time when I'm off tour there's only a
few dates left but then I'll be back in
the in the clubs and I'll be trying to
build up time to get back on the road
how do you feel about I mean that road
life's different right it's different
but I'm uh uh fortunate enough that like
I can afford to bring my homie through
sharks saying who I'm gonna do a special
for him as well okay he's got like uh
he's opening up for you yeah he does my
feature stuff uh but he has like um he's
like a day job like an actual office job
so he's kind of doing a 20-minute thing
on like hey this is why office jobs suck
and here's how to still like kind of
advance in the workplace while not
giving a [ __ ] right and it's funny it's
actually funny I'm not saying that very
relatable funny I wouldn't bring them up
yeah uh and then my camera guy also
named kev611 slash bodyguard camera
bodyguard so I got at least them too and
usually one other person maybe two and
so I have a little crew that like keeps
you company keeps me company because
yeah again I'm I've never done anything
remotely close to but like I don't want
to be on the road alone and just like
there's just random [ __ ] talking to
me and I'm so [ __ ] bored and
miserable that like I entertain the
offer right right right keep me out of
trouble yeah just keep me out the
[ __ ] mix man keep me out the mix I'm
here yeah I'm cheating on my way for my
homies and then just enjoy all the food
in every city yeah I know I've gained
like 20 pounds yeah I can only imagine
dude if I was on the road like that
because I'll be I'm in New York right
now and we're like I've been on keto for
like since May yeah yeah and I was like
you know what
nah yeah yeah [ __ ] that dude I need
pizza son you need something I don't
drink I don't smoke I don't do drugs I'm
faithful I'm eating junk food [ __ ] you
for sure I'm taking this cake to the
face yeah there it is man Akash I
appreciate you pulling up God bless man
thank you yes sir fire